welcome back to New Rock starss I'm Eric
Boss and Marvel Studios looks to be
finally answering one of its longest
burning questions what exactly is the
secret ingredient of the super soldier
serum that gave us Steve Rogers Captain
America and by extension Wolverine Hulk
Abomination Bucky Barnes Red Hulk Isaiah
Bradley John Walker Red Guardian
She-Hulk and now with a Thunderbolts
approaching Century an absolutely
Bonkers character from the more recent
years of Marvel Comics who seems to be
the villain or at least anti-hero of the
Thunderbolts film originally cast as St
Yun and then reported to be a role
offered to Louis pman who you might
remember as Bob from Top Gun Maverick
and according to our writer Gina someone
with a mouth so small that we need a
super cut of his mouth framed beside
normal siiz foods you may have heard a
lot about Sentry in the past year with
Steven young announced for the role
before backing out and yes by the way
his name is pronounced Steven Yun not
Steven Yun he had a whole segment with
Conan about this give it a watch it's
just Yun and you had never corrected me
and after seeing all this Sentry stuff
you may have thought oh Sentry another
Marvel super soldier character but with
insane Superman powers and a mental
health angle yes that is a case here but
trust me there is a lot more to this
character and in what Marvel sees in him
that makes Bob from Top Gun Maverick a
very exciting Bob Reynold Sentry Sentry
could be the missing piece of where
Marvel super soldier serum really came
from and what I believe the truth is is
pretty horrifying hey new rock stars is
doing a live show in Los Angeles on
February 15th at brain dead Studios it's
one night only ticket still available in
the description so the news that Louis p
is being considered for century was
actually first reported by scooper
Daniel Rickman last week and since
confirmed by Outlets like The Hollywood
Reporter century was created by Paul
Jenkins and Jay Lee released in
September 2000 essentially they wanted
Marvel's version of Superman not
necessarily in values because they
already had that with Captain America
but rather in power set but in terms of
his personality they wanted an over
theill guy struggling with an addiction
who had a tight relationship with his
dog so Rick vich who co-developed the
character had the idea to market the
character's introduction as a figure
from Marvel Comics from back in the 1940
40s like a creation of Stanley and Jack
Kirby with versions of this character
drawn in that older art style and old
school dialogue but that due to some
cataclysmic event everyone in the
universe forgot about Century's
existence including Bob Reynolds himself
so the century number one opens with Bob
just waking up in bed as an average
overweight dude battling alcoholism and
struggling with his mental health just
trying to get through the process of
taking his dog outside but this first
issue flashes back to these memories of
this whole other life where Bob was a
superhero named Sentry and passed eras
of history someone who had taken a super
soldier serum a thousand times more
potent than the one given to Steve
Rogers giving him the power of 1 million
exploding Suns his power set is wild
folks Sentry can manipulate reality he
can use telepathy he can fly and have
super strength and durability and go
toe-to-toe with pretty much any Marvel
character from Hulk to galactus's Herald
Tera to Galactus himself he's resistant
to Rogues energy absorption he could
fight Dr Doom in fact one of the most
memorable kills is when Sentry
completely rips IES in half he's
considered to be one of the deadliest
Marvel Comics characters in terms of his
power set now the downside for him is he
has to share his Consciousness with his
arch nemesis called the void which
actually takes the Persona of his dog in
the first issue that dog is even right
there in the opening panel the void is
kind of like a dark life force that
takes many forms and is attributed to
many sources from the judeo-christian
god to the angel of death according to
Norman Osborne to a mind virus from
Mastermind that was put in Cent's mind
or even just Bob's own subconscious in a
kind of metaphysical explanation that
all human beings have a dark side of
their subconscious and that Bob's
subconscious is just this void form so
when Steven Yun was announced to play
Sentry in Thunderbolts some people
wondered why would they cast Glenn from
The Walking Dead in this role what does
Sentry have to do with the Thunderbolts
well folks it wasn't just The Walking
Dead that got the attention of Marvel's
casting directors for a role like Sentry
it was also Steph Jan's performance in
Invincible obviously as Yun voices the
half viltrumite superhero tasked with
protecting Earth from the merciless
Empire that his father hailes from is
kind of Earth's unwitting champion and
him taking on this role leads to some
insane Ultra violence but also Young's
Emmy womy performance in the series beef
on Netflix in which he plays an
extremely unhealthy contractor with
severe anger issues and I'm telling you
just watch beef and you'll be like oh
yeah this is sentury and while I would
have loved seeing Yun in the role of
sentury or several other roles in the
MCU I also see where they're going with
Lewis Pullman an accomplished actor in
his own right and you don't have to look
much further than his very first line on
screen in Top Gun Maverick when did you
get in oh i' I've been here the whole
time in addition to sharing the name Bob
I've been here the whole time gets that
exactly why centry could be such a cool
character in the context of the
Thunderbolt story The whole idea of
Sentry is that he was here the whole
time and no one remembers he existed
senty needs to just function as someone
who in the MCU has been the background
since the beginning intertwined with the
origins of all of these super soldiers
and in the MCU especially Phase 1 the
plan for most of their Heroes at least
the ones who weren't Androids aliens or
Wizards was for them to be Warriors
Juiced up with this stuff super soldier
serum super soldier serum was the name
of the mystery formula from Dr Abraham
Erskine given to Steve Rogers an older
version of it had been tested on Johan
Schmidt in 1940 but that wasn't ready
and it turned Schmid into Red Skull but
the serum had been perfected by the time
it was given to Steve Rogers and we
don't know what fully was in that serum
only that it was enhanced with Bays from
Howard Stark and that urine cryptically
said this about it theum amplifies
everything that is inside so good
becomes great bad becomes worse now we
know that this line was really just
meant to establish Steve Rogers moral
character but from a chemical and
biological standpoint how would a serum
amplify one's moral and ethical
behavioral instincts like morals and
ethics don't come from one's DNA or
one's Anatomy they come from nurture
external factors the world in which
someone grows up and the life path that
that person chooses to walk so the fact
that a serum could read interpret and
respond to aspects of a subject's soul
tells us that there must be some Divine
quality to it whatever this secret
ingredient is must come from a place in
the MCU where morality can be measured
and where else could that be than from
the gods now February 15th new rock
stars is putting up another live show in
Los Angeles at brain dead Studios at
these new rockstars live shows we cover
the latest releases we have some special
guests we have a great time geeking out
with you in the audience in person and
we get to do stuff that we never get to
do here on YouTu the last one of these
we did in November it's just been a
complete blast it's just been amazing to
meet all of you so we want to do another
one of these branded Studios this is
awesome old school single Screen Theater
they have a beer garden they have some
really cool merch so if you're in Los
Angeles we would love to see you there
February 15th it's going to be days
after the Super Bowl and a day after the
release of Madam web so we're going to
have so much to talk about so much to
theorize on and so much to just recover
from so let's do it together you can get
a ticket by clicking the link in the
description or by heading to dice.fm in
searching for new rock stars tickets are
limited so grab yours now we'll see you
in person on February 15th in the past I
know I've theorized that the secret
ingredient in the super soldier serum
could be the heart-shaped herb of
wakanda like the same thing that
empowers Steve Rogers could be the same
thing that empowers tala season two of
what if even confirmed that Howard Stark
received the vibranium for the Prototype
Shield as a gift from T chaka's father
perhaps other W Condon resources were
shared with the project rebirth team
alternatively we could look at Odin who
is known for having words in his charms
and with Hela in what if season 2 a
mercy charm with the serum Schmidt was
looking for godly power like what he
admired in Odin and we should note that
the serum and the Tesseract are the same
blue color and the Tesseract gave kahori
a special power and what if this Godly
magical cocktail was what several years
of weapon plus experimentation would try
and fail to reproduce Steve Rogers was
weapon one and Wolverine of course was
Weapon X weapon 10 Isaiah Bradley
introduced in the Falcon the Winter
Soldier and expected to return in
Captain America Brave New World was also
part of weapon 1 weapon four was
Theodore sales AKA man thing whom we
meet in werewolf By Night weapon six is
Luke Cage weapon 7 Frank Simpson nuke
both characters that are out technically
MCU Cannon by Marvel Studios Annex the
Netflix series and yes while Weapon X is
Wolverine the success with Wolverine
spun off Deadpool in x23 and x24 who we
meet in Logan now Bucky Barnes received
a different version of the super soldier
serum from Hydra and it was suggested
that Red Guardian received a less
effective version of the serum from the
Russian government Hydra scientists
continued Brewing their own version of
the serum and that's the versions that
were taken by the flag Smashers and by
John Walker Bruce Banner and Emil
blansky were part of this same weapon
plus program as thadius Ross used Ur
skine AKA Dr reinstein Serum with Stark
Industries vit rays and when Ross
inevitably becomes Red Hulk in Captain
America 4 he will be part of that
lineage too and She-Hulk by receiving
Bruce Banner's blood is also a recipient
of this whole super soldier tradition so
centry would really join all these
Marvel heroes and I think they're going
to introduce them in order to reveal the
possible origin of the super soldier
sium what made all these characters so
Godly and I think it's why Val in
Thunderbolts is putting together this
particular lineup of super soldiers in
order to stop Sentry so in the comics
Sentry gets a special version of Steve
Rogers serum that is a thousand times
stronger but in the age of the sentury
miniseries it suggested that the sentury
is really an entity that comes from
Another Universe seeking a new home and
it uses the serum as kind of its conduit
and that is really what makes centry
serum so crazy giving him Cosmic level
abilities and the ability to stop
galatis so what would be the MCU version
of this I think the pieces are already
in place in the MCU and this could be
what finally answers some of the more
nagging questions we've had in the
recent era I think Dr Ur Skin's mystery
ingredient and the heart-shaped herb
Sharon origin and like vibranium these
were all gifts from outer space from the
gods that meteorite that struck wakanda
was what scattered vibranium and enrich
the soil of wakanda with minerals that
allowed the heart-shaped nerve to grow
but remember there was something else
before the vibranium meteorite that
struck Earth from space the celestial
seed that eventually grew into teut
inside of Earth's core I actually
speculated that that could have been the
same meteorite that hit the Yucatan
Peninsula 65 million years ago and
created the Gulf of Mexico and the MCU
established talokan which is off the
base of the Yucatan Peninsula and that
that event could have given Neymar's
people their own version of the
heart-shaped herb and minerals that they
used in their Tech so I believe that
vibranium origin was the celestials
their bodies may even be made out of a
form of vibranium the celestials are
Marvel's gods and they gave Earth this
Advanced unnatural mineral in order to
expedite their eventual exporation Earth
wasn't meant to keep any of this stuff
because Earth was going to be destroyed
it was just all going to be part of a
cleanup operation but the Eternal
stopped this process and screwed
everything up from the celestials
perspective so that is why I believe we
are seeing rumors and speculation that
the corpse of tiamut might finally come
back into the MCU and factor into the
Thunderbolts plot and some speculation
that this corpse might be a supply for
adamantium in the MCU because we would
be talking about a mineral from the god
gods and adamantium is an alloy of
vibranium I think this mineral is a gift
from the gods and it found its way into
the serum that was given to Steve Rogers
and a more concentrated dose of that
given to Sentry like I think we're going
to learn that somewhere on planet Earth
in the MCU is a deposit of a special
mineral water a kind of celestial
Fountain of Youth and the one that Ur
skine found is what led him to perfect
the serum that he gave to Steve Rogers I
don't think it's crazy to say that all
super soldiers either ones with the
serum or ones enhanced with vibrating
ratam mantium in the case of Wolverine
all these guys are really blessed with
the powers of gods because that would
explain why Steve Rogers was able to
resist Thanos for a moment before Thanos
used the stones on him in Infinity War
to inject super soldier serum into one's
bloodstream is to literally harness the
power of gods to play God oneself and to
allow the godly power to puppet you
after deeming your moral character to be
worthy so I think in Thunderbolts we're
going to learn the cataclysmic event
that affected the world's memory of
centy was the emergence of teat Cent
would be a kind of celestials human
champion on Earth arish Avatar the way
black panther is the Avatar of Bast and
moonnight is the Avatar of konu Sentry
isn't the guardian of Earth he is the
guardian of the celestials authority and
that will make him view tiamat's corpse
as his Turf leading to the adamantium
turf war that Val will want to win at
all costs wait a minute did I just make
the case that the missing ingredient of
the superultra serum was Celestial
Seaman oh good God well Steven y dodged
a bullet hey if you like this video give
us a like and smash that subscribe
button my friends you can support new
rockstars by grabbing some merch at nerd
rot. shop follow me at eaos follow new
rockstars thanks for watching I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
everybody